adrian snapped a four-game winning
streak four decisions
before his last loss i mean he he lost
his last time out against minnesota
it was a rough outing for him five
innings five runs he had a four run
fourth inning that he allowed he does
keep the ball in the ballpark that's a
big deal as we talked about on our open
bernos with six home runs last night
adrian hasn't given up one in a while
liner to the left yelich
right in his tracks battling the lights
a bit
went away
goldschmidt hitless in his three at bats
last night did draw two walks and scored
twice
and he strikes out goldsmith two gone
four seamer that time up and in
94 miles an hour and right on the inner
half of the plate inside corner and up
in the zone and goldsmith a strikeout
victim now tyler o'neal here comes
hauser hey
struck him out swinging
three are up three are down and the
cardinals are finished in the opening
inning guanghun kim getting the start
for the saint louis cardinals returned
to the rotation sunday afternoon against
pittsburgh
gave up three hits three consecutive but
other than that he was very very good
and luis cerius will lead things off
swinging a drive to left center indeed
get up
get up get out of here and weigh gone
for luis arias and the brewers have the
lead
in the opening inning on his 19th
long ball of the year
luis aureus
get one out of here and that one well
into the brewers bullpen after giving up
15 runs yesterday six home runs the
brewers with a perfect answer first home
run ever allowed to the brewers from kim
this one to left center that's going to
get down for a base hit for willy adams
back to back face hits and christian
yelling is coming up
to right a base hit three straight hits
for the brewers offense to start the
night escobar 24 home runs on the year
for him this is escobar the switch
hitter that's hit up the middle oh what
a play here sosa turns it's a double
play
edmond
sosa spinning and then over to goldie
for the double play that should have
been a base hit it should have been an
rbi but what it is is a double play the
ball was smoked right past kim and tommy
edmond came out of nowhere to catch it
turn around throw right on the money to
sosa who was alertly looking for the
throw and he turned and completed the
double play and the pitch
swaying and a miss struck him out and he
gets out of it
with minor damage now the left-handed
batting rowdy toles another 2-2 pitch
lined into right center field
base hit kane going to turn the corner
here's the throw from carlson not in
time and it gets into the dugout the
brewers are going to get a run carlson
cut it off his throw hit right in front
of the bag at third
and uh it got lorenzo kane looked like
it got him in the hand what are the odds
of that now the pitch by kim hit to left
and deep in the corner should get off
the wall it will bounce over
for a ground rule double and luke maylie
just knocked in a run everything up in
the strike zone for kim right now and
the brewers taking advantage of it
down the left field line of fair ball
melee's going to score
maria's on his way to second here comes
the throw and urias is going to be out
at second base he's gonna get a single
and an rbi to make it four nothing
another outfield assist from tyler
o'neill a great throw from him he's got
a terrific throwing on let me talk about
his power
at the plate he's got a pretty strong
accurate arm and a good throw in his
second base to cut down aureus trying to
stretch it into a double adamus to
shallow center bader can't get there
base hit willy adams he's two for two he
spell the end of the night for kim very
short start for him inning plus 3-2
pitch
out to deep right carlson beck dropped
the screen
escobar hustling to second the throw is
in time and got him it's an outfield
assist the second of the night for the
cardinals
the first by o'neal this one dylan
carlson
about midway up on that fence carlson
plays it well and throws a strike into
second
base been many full counts let alone
three ball counts against adrian hauser
3-2 pitch and it's a called third strike
sinker at 94 right down the middle
and edmond took it for a third strike
and there's two down now for tyler
o'neill here's the o2
swinging a miss he struck him out with a
sinker up and in and hauser with a
couple of strikeouts here in the fourth
inning and another one two three inning
54 pitches for hauser through four
innings of work he struck out five and
he is pitched exclusively from the wind
up
until now there's a base hit to left
arnado snaps the perfecto through four
innings for adrian hauser
ground ball towards the middle this
could be two adams steps on the back
fires to first law what a pick by tolez
that was not a short hop that was a
tough in-between hop and a bullet-like
throw from
willy adams
count in really good shape for hauser no
more than 17 pitches and any inning for
him allows you to pitch deep in games
liner off of hauser
collects himself throws the first in
time inning over boy that one got
hauser's square so hauser works around a
lead off single here in the top of the
seventh and he's gone seven scoreless so
far we go to the bottom of seven it's a
four nothing lead for the brewers only
six starters this year for the brewers
have recorded an out in the eighth
inning
swinging a miss he struck him out
sixth strikeout for hauser his first
strikeout since the fourth so said the
play kicks deals bullseye struck him out
looking
and the inning is over wow
what an outing for adrian hauser
two hits 91 pitches tonight his career
high is 104. after getting blown out in
game one
now the brewers get a tremendous start
from hauser's trying to finish it off
and pick up his first complete game
shutout
fly ball right field jackie bradley jr
makes the catch it's a complete game
shutout for adrian hauser
101 pitches and pure brilliance from
hauser seven full seasons since the last
complete game shutout for a brewery's
pitcher
[Music]